in the Fast and Furious series Death is
little more than a speed bump so it's
not a huge shock that a character
returns after their seeming end in fast
X but you do have to wonder just how it
happened obviously spoilers for fast
eggs ahead but there's a lot of
ridiculous plots where sir happen
throughout director Louis laterriase and
producer star Vin diesels bombastic
magnum opus fast X but not quite as hard
to swallow as a final scene's shocking
return no we're not talking about the
long-spoiled mid-credit scene that
brings Dwayne Johnson's Luke Hobbs back
into the fold that sequence is
astonishing for its own reasons but what
truly defies logic is a revelation that
for some unknown period of time gisel
yashar has been hiding in what appears
to be the nuclear submarine from the
fate of the Furious the character first
appeared in 2009's Fast and Furious play
by Future Wonder Woman star Gal Gadot
and Metro tragic demise in Fast and
Furious 6. also we thought like a former
lover hun gisela's returned from the
dead bringing with her a whole slew of
unanswered questions but then again the
series already laid the groundwork for a
tenuously reasonable explanation for her
return though whether it increases or
undermines a dramatic tension is Up For
Debate
we'll have to Giselle died
and I didn't know what to do
I was aimless in hindsight it would
almost be more surprising if Gisele
hadn't survived a fast six demise
characters from this franchise have
survived fiery explosions gunshots to
the head and about a hundred deadly car
accidents so falling from around 15 feet
onto an airplane Runway probably doesn't
do a lot of damage in this universe even
moving at the speed of a plane about to
take off what is less believable in the
fast universe is that she wouldn't
immediately reconnect with Han which is
likely why they'll explain her fate
death the same way as they explained his
through the intervention of Mr Nobody
and the agency aside from the fact that
nobody faked Han's death for his own
gain and could conceivably have done so
for Giselle his involvement is really
the only way the Antarctica Prison Break
subplot makes any sense Brie Larson's
test is Mr nobody's daughter and her
goal seems to be to help Letty Escape so
she would logically need to have a
destination in mind for her so giselle's
Presence at the climax of this storyline
almost outright confirms that she's been
involved with the agency since her death
and is there the behest of Tess though
we aren't yet sure what Tess Giselle and
the agency are planning it seems certain
that they've had this contingency ready
for some time with Mr Nobody and this
Ward little nobody out of commission the
treacherous agent Ames has been given
the proverbial keys to the kingdom
perhaps Mr Nobody noticed a change in
the tides and began to fear Dante and
ames's nefarious takeover of the agency
with a sense of paranoia rivaling that
of Nick Fury nobody might have closed
ranks and kept a circle of trust as
small as possible which would explain
why he couldn't have revealed that
Giselle was still alive even to Han
that means I can trust you
and that
is very rare in this line of work
in this scenario nobody may have
sequestered the nucleus submarine as a
last Resort's base of operations for
Tess Giselle and possibly even Hobbes if
he is also part of this clandestine
world saving scheme we're sure to get
the low down on what Giselle and Hobbs
have been up to in the upcoming sequel
or sequels to fast X